les pharmacies du centre-ville de
montréal sont en rupture de stock
il semble quasiment impossible de
trouver des masques chirurgicaux
ce pharmacien l'avouent ils n'arrivent
plus à répondre à la demande et des
clients qui viennent à tout les jours de
mardin et masques oui en effet pour le
nouveau vice d'une bannière à l'autre à
montréal comme à winnipeg
on retrouve des étagères vides ici
le commis espère en recevoir jeudi mais
rien n'est moins sûr il leur a fallu
visiter cette pharmacie du centre ville
de montréal pour finalement trouver un
paquet de masquer le dernier qui
restaient dans le magasin sur internet
certains vendeurs profitent de
l'inquiétude pour gonfler les prix
jusqu'à 500 $ pour deux boîtes
et pourtant ce genre de masques ne
protègent même pas efficacement contre
le coronavirus c'est pas du tout une
mesure de protection contre commandes
pour la population et surtout pas dans
le contexte actuel au québec là où ses
potes on vit pas du tout la même
situation qu'en chine en fait les
médecins et les pharmaciens rappelle que
se laver les mains qui protège mieux que
de porter un masque mêlerait mali
geneviève main c'est vraiment ce qui est
important pour l'instant comme les
médecins les pharmaciens ne recommande
pas le port du masque rien ne sert de se
précipiter pour en acheter ici vincent
maisonneuve rens au canada montréal